the squad ride is back for nfl kickoff
week and there's only nine days left
till the return of football we'll get
your take on all our favorite markets
from rushing yards to rookie of the year
to mvp and more we're also giving away
killer prizes including nfl jerseys over
a thousand dk dollars and an all
expenses paid trip to vegas for one
lucky person and a friend
but this isn't a commercial it's a live
show so let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the squad ride brought to you
by draftkings live in the bleacher
report app nfl kickoff is right around
the corner i'm connor rogers joining me
is the man of the people the guy you
want to get on his good side he's got a
lot to give away today that is greg
ivory and not one but two nfl legends in
vince young and my old friend now keith
to leave gentlemen great to have you
here what's going on how we feeling
football time baby let's go
hell yeah yeah
season is here yes sir that's here
that's right that's right and to kick
things off let's take a look at our best
moments from last season with a little
help from you the fans
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
man it feels good to win i'll tell you
that much and we teamed up with
draftkings to give a look at our best
bets a lot of in-depth different odds
and sorts like that greg what else we
got in store man
connor we got a lot man in today's show
i'm gonna be giving out over a thousand
dk dollars five nfl jerseys a trip to
vegas for you and a friend
and as always always always hoodies
hoodies hoodies and actually i feel like
giving out one
right now everybody that's tapped into
the squad ride know what this is right
here akiv
v y connor this right here is the handy
dandy ipad this is how everybody will
get hoodies is how you get your money
this is how you get jerseys this right
here is the plug uh we've got an
offensive expert and the defensive
expert on the show i need you guys to
get in the comments and tell me who
you would trust to cash your bet a star
quarterback or a lockdown defense i'm
giving away 250 dk dollars and a jersey
but before i do that v y talk to me who
would you rather have a star quarterback
or a lock down defense
you got to go with your boy v1 baby
i mean i like oh i know v while we're
going to go with the tv baby
vy locking in the qb a keep come on man
which way you leaning which way you
going i'ma ride with vy i'm gonna go
with the quarterback i'm betting i want
to bet on the least amount of people
that's possible right so the defense
yeah i'm saying you got to worry about
too many people i'ma rob the quarterback
man one man show okay hey
y'all gonna give me and to leave that uh
that vegas trip we'll take that hey i'm
telling you how we ate how we apply for
that how we apply it
vegas vegas trip with v y and the key
might be legendary we might gotta talk
to the producers about that one but uh
let me hop into these comments man i'm
into these comments and i'm seeing star
q be like no other i'm seeing star qv
the comments are moving so fast hold on
i have to lock in here we go uh kp
philly330 says lockdown d shout out to
you kp philly you're walking away with a
hoodie raiders zero eight one eight says
lock down d shout out to you raider zero
raider0818
you're also walking away with hoodie or
i'm going to give out the jersey right
now i'm going to give out the jersey and
dk dollars uh the jersey is going to the
jersey is going to here we go i got
jack zaymans jack zamens going with
lockdown d
defense wins championships that's what
they're saying on uh in the comments eve
i know you like that
championship we chat a bit
that is right hey and i'm gonna give
away uh this jersey now i'm gonna give
away a jersey here we go in the comments
and i have
not dk metcalf not dk metcalf says star
quarterback that's the one person i
chose that said star quarterback so
shout out to you not dk metcalf you are
walking away with a jersey connor
let's get this thing going man let's get
yeah let's take a look what the audience
have to say star quarterback or lockdown
defense we know how we're feeling over
here and it's a lopsided answer they're
taking the beat wide they're taking the
star quarterback
not much of a surprise there all right
keep this thing moving let's get to what
the audience has been waiting for it's
time to talk our favorite bets let's
dive in we're starting with rushing
yards there's been a top dog in this
category for the last two years but a
lot of players with big expectations
this year when you look at those totals
for rushing yards over
under and here's the top eight right
here obviously a lot of different
expectations of course the expectations
are really really high for christian
mccaffrey returning this year the young
buck and jonathan taylor nick chubb
expected to have a huge season greg what
do you need from the people right now as
we see these rushing yard totals
connor i need everybody in the comments
get in the comments start typing and
tell us
who's going to have the most wrestling
yards who do you think what's your
what's your best bet for rushing yards
actually what's your best bet for
restaurants that's who's going to have
the most but what's your best bet you
can tell me in words you could tell me
an emojis you could tell me a gifts get
creative
uh i'm giving away hoodies and also i'm
giving away 250 dk dollars v y
who do you think is the best
rushing yard bet on the board that's
easy tighten up first of all tighten up
let's go with the big guy mr henry and
it's definitely going to be over
definitely
akib who you rolling with
i'm gonna ride with i'm a ride with
christian mccaffrey yeah i'm saying sam
donald takes some of that pressure off
of him and uh he do for a big year man
he missed the whole last season so you
ready to go absolutely and i i'm gonna
go with jonathan taylor man oh vince you
know all right
go ahead vince got a little different
i'm gonna stop right now you don't know
about it
why that's not a good [ __ ] why v why
because donald that guy tried to see him
play
for the jets i saw him play too much me
why that's the problem no good
so that mean that mean they gonna lean
on that run game that's yeah i'm saying
that's part of that's part of my
reasoning right there vy
now it's not a good thing
he stay healthy i think you you good
easy work man
yeah i'm kind of thinking what keeb is
thinking only a different team i'm going
with jonathan taylor the colts have had
all kinds of quarterback problems all
summer whether it's injuries whether
whatever is going on but carson wins
week by week they're going to hand
jonathan taylor the ball a lot and we
saw what he did in just what 13 games
last year absolutely killing it so
jonathan taylor easy over hammer it what
do you got
greg uh
i mean before i get into my pick let me
get into the comments because you guys
know i am a man of the people i want to
hear what they're talking about uh
i got james robinson austin gay says
james robinson about to get all the
touches shout out to you i am uh you're
walking away with a hoodie uh
oh jesus the the comments are going
today i got double d says m c squared ak
cmc hey he rocking with you a key
uh
here we go here we go i'm gonna get
about one more hoodie
joshua lopez 10 hey joshua josh what's
good bro he's my college teammate i
think hey what up mate hey he said rahim
moser rahim moser shout out to you josh
uh you're walking away with a hoodie uh
before i give out the dk dollars let me
hop in here let me hop in here
i saw a guy by the name of ezekiel
elliott only having to rush for 1100
yards
zeke last year everybody said where was
zeke where was he
he rest for 9.79 last year all he has to
do is go get 11 z
feed him eat zeke give my guy to 1100
yards i'm taking that bet uh
let me give out these 250 dk dollars
y'all
let me give out these 250 dk dollars uh
here we go i'm back into the request i
mean not the request i'm used to being
on the instagram live but i am back into
the comment back into the comments and i
see
oh this is a good one
guy with water his name is guy with
water con marmite with water
josh
jacobs josh jacobs i like that rocking
with josh jacobs so uh
shout out to you you're walking away
with 250 dollars in dk i love it all
right you buy with dk dollars
more money
more money
good bets like these ones today
absolutely and visit draftkings for more
rushing yard totals let's keep it moving
though this is a little more fun over
under anyone could do that let's put our
money where our mouth is for rushing
touchdowns leader you pick one here
obviously the reigning king the two-time
king derek henry sitting at the top he's
done it the last two years but a lot of
contenders in the pool this year
obviously nick chubb huge expectations
there in cleveland zeke always going to
be getting those goal line carries aaron
jones coming off really good
back-to-back years for green pay green
bay if you didn't get those dk dollars
don't worry we're gonna give away more
stuff right now greg tell the people
what's in store
i'm about to tap in with the homie key
to leave and ask for his pick on who he
thinks will have the most rushing
touchdowns this season let's take a look
at the odds one more time let's take a
look at those odds one more time please
get those odds up because i gotta go
down the list we got derrick henry plus
450 we got dalvin cook plus four i'm mad
akeeb you see this the people see this
you say you want money man you say that
you about your money you trying to win
so may talk to us
before before before but hold up my bad
my bad my bad buddy before i get your
pick before i get your pick i just meet
the people
in the comments i need y'all to get in
the comments and tell me who you think
is scoring the most russian touchdowns
this year i'm giving out 150 dollar
jersey gift card to the to anybody to a
person who matches the right answer as
my guy a keep to leaves so you got to
get the same answer as my guy keep to
leave in order to win this jersey gift
card a key
who do you have leading the league in
rushing touchdowns this year my guy
when i look at that list right
i look at aaron jones and i see that
plus 1800 and that's where i really like
the bet at right if i'm a bet i want to
win something when i bet you know what
i'm saying but
i'm gonna be safe here you can see him
be safe
i'm gonna go with derek here that's
right akeeb don't reinvent the wheel man
don't really gotta go here baby that's
right that's right vince what do you
think about that plus 450 you know i'm
saying so we'll make it work
yeah make smart moves you don't want to
be losing no money now
all right all right my boy my boy keith
said derek here by i know you got to be
happy with that right like yeah i'm very
proud of them i'm very proud of my my
guy down there in dallas made a great
decision right there buddy
so yeah i'm going with the same thing
i'm going with henry too
all right all right i think i think i
think i gave him enough time in the
comments to comment so let's hop in here
man the handy dandy ipad is out the
handy dandy ipad is out and uh my boy
akeeb said there can we so someone who
took
derek henry is walking away with 150
gift card i'm about to get into the
comments right now
uh here we go
i got josh lopez is back in the comments
talking about derek carey but you're not
walking away with the 150 no josh uh
shout out to you though brody i got john
clyde08 johnclyde08 also rocking with
harry hey henry is taking over the
comments
that's the easy one it's the easy one
john clyde 08 is walking away with a
hoodie all right y'all it's time to give
away this jersey it's time it's time to
give away this jersey i'm in the
comments
d card three d card three picked derek
henry so therefore d card three
you are walking away with the jersey
gift card shout out to you all right we
have a lot more to give away including a
trip to las vegas that's right you're
going to want to stick around
yeah
as much as vince wants the trip we're
not giving it to vince or a key we'll
get their own trip there to win that
yeah yeah you got to win that so let's
keep this movement and talk passing
yards passing yard totals over unders
obviously patrick mahomes and tom brady
sitting right at the top there with huge
expectations this year somebody who's
done it for a long time and matt ryan
and then a newcomer in justin herbert
greg what do you need from the people
right now i know there's going to be a
lot of different takes on this one this
isn't derek henry rushing touchdowns
it's going to be a little different
across the board
hey what i need everybody to do get in
the comments use your twitter fingers
use your instagram fingers whatever it
is your bleacher report at fingers man
get in the comments and tell us your
best bet for passing yards total you can
tell me in words
you can tell me gifts
you can tell me in emojis i'ma say that
probably one more time but i'm giving
away hoodies man at 250 dk dollars vy
talking to you right now vy who do you
think has the best value
for the total passing yard back
well this is another easy bet cause i
know y'all be watching kansas city
cheese right
you see what you see with that y'all see
what that young man throwing the ball to
over there
man so definitely i got him going over
for sure catching my homes for sure
that's easy that's another easy bit
i keep who you rolling with here
i see he right pat my homes that's the
easy bet
the easy [ __ ] you don't pick up no
money yeah i'm saying
pick up that money when you bet
therefore
i'm gonna go
matt ryan i'm gonna go matt ryan over
matt ryan in that over young new weapon
young new weapon
yeah
they gonna be losing every game so
they're gonna throw that [ __ ] around
all game you know what i'm saying that's
why he gonna lead the league
that's not a good he'll have nobody
throw the ball to
oh he's not waiting for the ball to now
well i'll say this i'm going with
somebody that has too many people to
throw the ball dude that's dak prescott
whether it's cd lamb michael gallup
amari cooper on and on and on i'm going
with the safe money there all right greg
before we get to your pick what are the
people saying right now
ah yes i am in the comments
handy dandy ipad is back in my hand i
got
i got b losser 74 b losser 74 says josh
allen shout out to you be lost or 74.
josh allen might be a good bet uh
i forget your your username i lost you
man the comments are going uh i got not
fred warner 55 not fred warner 55
justin herbert i don't dislike that
justin herbert is a slinger justin
herbert is a slinger i got one more
hoodie i'm giving away one more hoodie
here we go uh
steven durant steven duron rogers big
year from aaron rodgers all right he's
rocking with aaron rodgers before i give
away this 250 dk dollars let me hop in
here you guys all went over we see over
with uh keys pick we see over with uh
my guy v wise pick and uh my guy connor
went over with that
prescott so let me switch it up a little
bit a little switcheroo in here you know
what i'm saying
i'm going with tom brady and we're not
going over we're going under
super bowl hangover is a thing what it
is a thing my guy tom listen to me by
tom threw for forty four thousand six
hundred and thirty three yards last year
don't drink that i believe his total
juice man his total his total sitting at
4 750.
in the half don't do it don't do it
don't do not bet against tom brady yeah
never again
never again
what they saying in the comments man i
want to see what the people saying hey
hey the people the people they all man
let me let me
keep guessing i guess the key want me to
give him some more hoodie so i'm gonna
give some more hoodies out uh i got
patty mahomes steel curtain oh wait
patty home shout out to your walk away
with hoodie uh here we go uh greg greg
my guy to goat says matt stafford matt
stafford is
uh he's rivaled max davis shout out to
you walkway woody hey right now i'm
gonna give away 250 dk dollars
here we go 250 dk dollars
250 dk dollars too
here we go bad sports takes bad sports
takes i'm going with brady he's going to
show up my home he's fading me so guess
what i'm doing i'm showing him love i'm
showing him love by giving him 250 dk
dollars shout out to you
lost you shout out to who i just said i
lost you hopefully the producers heard
you all right visit draftkings for more
passing yards odds all right let's keep
this thing moving if you didn't get
those dk dollars don't worry i'm sure we
got a jersey in store for you maybe a
hoodie greg what is next on the giveaway
list what are we looking at now
bad sports picks was the person shout
out to you brother pixar
leave no shout outs everybody's get
shout outs here we go i'm about to tap
it with my boy v y though and as for his
picks on who
is going to have the most passing
touchdowns this year v y let's take a
look at the odds though
y'all already know there it is
there it is we i'm assuming i'm assuming
v y is going to go with the plus 500
pick but you guys see everybody on here
listen he's going right he's going that
plus uh 330. you know vy he ain't trying
to win no money oh no
he's safe but he's safe better yeah
he
like to come home with something you
know what i mean
they call it they call you a favorite
better vy but what i need everybody to
do y'all know what to do get in the
comments and tell me who you think is
throwing the most passion touchdowns and
i'm giving away a 150 jersey gift card
to one person who matches my guy's
v-wise answers
so v y
the people
need to know
who you picking
tom brady come on now
did y'all watch him
did y'all watch him last year anytime he
gets in the red zone he got two big guys
that he can throw the ball to and i
don't even need to say they name but
y'all know they name one play tight end
and one play wide out and those two guys
are deadly in the red zone
hey let's throw that back up one more
time i'd love to see those passing
touchdowns leader right here all right
so tom brady pretty high at the top of
course patrick mahomes as well
vincent akeeb looking at the dark horse
guys whether it's a matt stafford maybe
a dak prescott even pretty good odds
there plus 1200 you can make some bank
off of that for a guy that might win
comeback player of the year what are
some dark horse candidates you like on
this list
i really i really like stafford man
staffer got a chance you think about it
right the rams always average damn near
30th game right with
with jg you know i'm saying i stand
proposed to crank up the passing portion
of it they run all them little reverses
and them them sweeps them passes you
know i'm saying a quick little catch
they scored seven touchdowns a year off
of those you know i'm saying if you know
the rams offense so
yeah i don't know staffer got a chance
man
this is a high-powered offense now this
offense always score a bunch of points
all right greg what's going on in the
car oh vy you got another one
yeah i got uh that man he's he's back
and ready i know he's excited
so and then like you said earlier to all
those guys he could he could throw the
ball to over there galore so i'm just
happy to see him back so i know that's
gonna be my dark heart for sure
greg what are the people saying right
now what's going on
uh the people the people the people are
in the comments man uh look at br
betting look at pr betting they they
said to leak to leave like staff or vr
betting is in the comments shout out to
you be our bed uh let me get some
hoodies away though uh i got
i got i got
a guy with water is back lw one two two
joe burrow
joe
girl
shout out to ul
ltw one two two that is a dark horse you
were walking away with a hoodie um
dark
before but but let me get back let me
get back to the matter at hand let me
get back to the matter at hand the nfl
legend
said tom brady so someone who took tom
brady is walking away with 150
jersey gift card i'm gonna get into the
comments
again to figure out who am i gonna give
this
jersey gift card to
uh
k3n
dog two three twenty
k three n dog 2-3-20
actually you know you're walking away
with hoodie i'm gonna give it to
somebody else actually i'm gonna i
didn't like that take my back cutter my
bad b y my batter keep i did not like
that take i'm gonna give it away to
somebody how can we sign
in for that because i'm trying to win
some of these cards too now
i see
he said hey i see i see agr 60 agr 60
they pick tom brady shout out to you i'm
walking you're walking away with a
jersey man shout out to you you are
walking away with the jersey agr 60 agr
60. all right i love it we're not done
giving away stuff yet but you've heard
from us on passing and rushing leaders i
got to talk to draftkings analyst reid
fowler for some takes of his own take a
look
all right reed welcome to the squad ride
great to have you on want to go through
some players to watch to lead in a lot
of different categories let's start with
the running backs who do you think is
going to take home the rushing title
this year and have the most rushing
touchdowns yeah connor i think derek
henry don't don't make this really hard
right keep it simple right and
especially you just like a fine wine
connor he just gets better as time
progressed if you look at his november
december yards just in those two months
with other guys might be getting a
little cold might be getting a little
hurt guys got like around 3 500 yards in
those two months combining his career so
keep it simple go derek henry plus 350
on the dk sportsbook right now and for
tds i'm gonna go a little bit off maybe
not too much off the radar here but
antonio gibson plus 1800 seventh in
rushing touchdowns despite only
starting i think 10 games
last year and playing in only 14. this
guy's got a great defense behind him uh
you know i think he's a hall of fame
quarterback ryan fitzpatrick but most
people don't agree with that uh but i
like antonio gibson plus 1800 yeah i
love the volume for both of those guys i
think it's going to be a big second year
for gibson and like you said keep it
simple don't overthink derek henry art
moving on to the quarterbacks looking at
who we keep an eye on for passing title
to most yards and passing touchdowns
this year yeah i'm going justin herbert
plus 1400 i know there's a lot of guys
out there that you can take on this one
and this has a lot to do with scheme it
has a lot to do with maybe the defense
isn't that great i think matt ryan might
be a nice sneaky play for a lot of
people but julio jones not there kelvin
ridley we'll talk about him in a little
bit but justin herbert 5 000 yards conor
is probably the mark you're gonna have
to get over especially with that extra
game and look herbert was 289 i believe
289.1 yards per game last year if you
give him five more yards per game this
year he gets to that 5 000 mark and
especially with austin eckler healthy
that was a huge myth for herbert last
year and this guy i mean you know we see
him in wins too average 25 yards more
than in losses so the chargers even if
they're up they're still passing they
don't really have a running back connor
that can kind of seal games down like
derrick henry so i i think justin
herbert is fine at plus 1400 i think
he's gonna have a great season
and again going back to the passing
touchdowns josh allen at plus 750 brian
dabble is still there i think that's
huge for josh allen to to continue what
they did last year and stefan diggs is
absolutely fantastic i think manny
sanders only helps a guy like josh allen
get here i know you could potentially
run it in but over the last five years
41.6 is the touchdown total that has led
mahomes got to 50. i think you can see
josh allen get around that mid 40s and i
think that's good enough this year yeah
two guys with coming off huge breakout
seasons herbert with the rebuilt
offensive line josh allen like you said
with brian david there the continuity
has been pretty special to watch in
buffalo all right looking at who they're
throwing to who is going to take home
the title of most receiving yards and
this could be much much different who's
going to catch the most touchdowns who's
getting the looks in the red zone this
year yeah calvin ridley might have a
thousand at least a million targets this
year connor
i mean who else are you gonna pass it to
in that offense you know they're giving
matt ryan a couple more years you know
you know a little extra uh for the guy
who look honestly when you talk about
yards you talk about quarterbacks matt
ryan has gotten close to some of these
awards but calvin ridley is a guy who's
fifth in yards last season 16 yards per
target had eight 100 yard gains games
that that ranked first in the nfl and he
averaged nine targets when you put all
those together
it's really setting up for calvin really
to take that step forward as that number
one
and even though i do think that again
they're gonna have to score a lot of
touchdowns in atlanta to keep up i think
stefan dix pairing them up with josh
allen at plus 1600 to have the most
touchdowns and you know this better than
anyone connor targets are really the
only thing that we can predict quote
unquote predict in the nfl and the
galaxy on diggs you're just gonna get a
lot of targets i'm not too worried about
the other guys in that offense in terms
of what allen wants to do and what ryan
dabble wants to do downfield that's
stefan diggs 160 ish i got him projected
for this year again put him at nine ten
targets a game and from a value
perspective i think stefan diggs is the
best on the board right now yeah both
true number one wide receivers with not
much behind them right now i really like
the picks reid fowler draftkings analyst
thanks so much for joining man we
appreciate your time right thanks
all right great to talk to reed now time
to bring it back here let's talk player
awards and start with most important one
what are the odds to win the mvp award
obviously you see my homes at the top
that's been a theme of this show so far
the man is back and he is angry that is
aaron rodgers and then of course a big
time riser and josh allen you got justin
herbert at the bottom greg what's going
on in the comments right now what do we
need from the people as we get ready to
give away this las vegas trip everybody
get in the comments and tell us your
best bet for mvp i'm giving away hoodies
and i'm giving away 250 dk dollars v y
who do you think is the best bet to win
mvp i got to go with my guy mr wilson
i think this year is he going to finally
get over the hump
and have a better
uh playoff and championship game to get
that mvp so i'm going with my guy mr
wilson mr wilson
akeeb what are you going with
i'm a rod i'm a rod
i'm a ride with tommy i'm riding with
tommy brady man he he
caught his stride last year second half
of the season end of the season
i think he gonna pick up where he left
off you know what i'm saying he got the
graphic grasp of this high powered
offense bunch of deep balls
you know what i'm saying he got it
figured out and i know he know how he
gonna get his receivers the ball you
know how you gonna get every individual
guy the ball
this one tommy dangerous right here when
he
know exactly what he's doing so i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go with tommy fellas
i'm not getting fancy on you here i'm
going with pat my homes right this is a
team that loves to run up the score they
love to throw the ball and they like to
win a lot of games which matters a lot
here i think mahomes coming off that
super bowl loss rebuilt offensive line
still got great weapons there especially
tyreek hill he's going to make it happen
this year but greg before we get to your
taste
the comment who are the comments
agreeing with right now that's what i
want to know mommy brady ah let me see
hey they definitely definitely not
agreeing with something that never
happened before
it's going to happen
trust me i'm saying mr wilson is growing
up
i'm seeing i'm seeing russell wilson mvp
richie 21 shout out to you you walking
away with a hoodie uh i got lamar
jackson lamar jackson uh um
lamar jackson i'm pretty sure i can't
pronounce this
n-a-h-e-k-h-u-s-s-a-i-n those are for
our producers everybody's walking away
with a hoodie if i say your name so i
just want to make sure everybody gets uh
the roll call here we go back into the
comments i see rogers itw one two two
says rogers back to back mvps
uh no sir that's it for that that's it
for the hoodies for right now that's it
for the hoodies right now let me hop in
here y'all
i'm gonna go with josh allen
step out the box a little bit my guy
talks about that he likes value he likes
he likes money josh allen he's towards
the bottom of the list you know i mean
so i'm a rolling dice my guy josh allen
he uh he was top five in passing yards
last year
top five in passing yards last year top
five in passing touchdowns also rushed
for eight touchdowns i just think that
he's going to take his game up
and then hopefully you know win that mvp
so i'm putting my money together yeah he
is let me get back into this he is a
beast
he
he is a beast for show let me get back
into these comments and give away this
250 dk dollars uh i'm back into the
comments man i'm back into the comments
and i see
here we go
uh
eric uh
bridget eric bridget
said josh allen is a solid pick
shout out to you brother appreciate that
he's trying to get on greg's good side
see it worked hey you were walking away
with 250.
man man give greg a compliment walk away
at 250
to spend and if you want to do that you
can visit draftkings for more mvp odds
if you haven't won yet just stick around
longer give greg a compliment and you'll
probably walk away with something all
right
great
hey don't tell him to sauce
you tell him what's that
hey before i tap in with my boy v wyatt
and ask for his pick for the rookie of
the year
let's take a look at the odds let's take
a look at the odds for this rookie of
the year man it's rookie classic this is
it's an exciting rookie class and this
is exciting we got trevor lawrence up
top
justin fields
zach trey lands look at treyland sitting
at plus 750 ah i like that naji saying
that plus eight hundred uh what i need
all to do is get in the comments and
tell me who you think is throwing
no actually tell me who you think is
winning offensive rookie of the year
tell me who you guys think is winning
offensive rookie of the year uh
v y yes sir
yes sir the people want to know
the people want to know v y
who do you think
actually the producer just whispered in
my ear and said the people want to know
vy who do you think
is winning offensive rookie of the year
i got my man zach
i really like his decision making he
made in preseason the young man was
throwing the ball accurately
very very good
also
no turnover
so
that's pretty good it's kind of tough
too because some of these other guys are
not really even playing yet i think
justin definitely should be starting i
don't know why this other guy is
starting over him i will play him but
i will put pick him over zach but he's
not playing he's not gonna be playing as
much so i had to go with zach which i
definitely like his decision making
during pre-season making some really
awkward throws
yeah that's half the battle right there
can we fly that one more time guys i
would love to see the offensive rookie
of the year odds this is the problem
right you said it'd be why justin fields
not starting trey lance not starting you
know jamar chase slow summer over there
kyle pitts probably going to see a lot
of targets mac jones akeeb he's
officially the starter in new england
all right keeb let's hear from you who
do you like on this list
mac jones
first
first you gonna pick up paper he plus 1
000. so you're going to pick up paper if
you bet
and he got a
a solid old coordinator he got a solid
team around him man so
i like the squad he got around him man
josh mcdaniel's gonna make that [ __ ]
easy for him he gonna be able to just
get the ball out of his hands fast run
the football play defense man so
the win total the win total and the
stats man that that that that'll win it
for him
greg what do people think
uh hey the people are all over the place
man the people are i just want to give
away some hoodies because the people are
here i got naji out naji out it says
naji
shout out to you naji out
you are walking away with a hoodie i got
game pro uh
jamar chase game pro 50 says jamar chase
jamar chase and joe burrow will link uh
shout out to you game pro uh you were
walking away with hoodie uh all right so
i i i think it's time man i think it's
time my guy b.y said zach wilson so
somebody who says zach wilson is walking
away with the 150 jersey gift card back
into the handy dandy ipad right now
looking for this lucky contestant and i
came across
raider909 it hurts my heart to pick you
raider909 because i am a niner fan and
we had the rivalry with you guys but
raider909 i'm not no hater
you are walking away with the 150
uh
150
jersey gift card uh shout out to you
brother all right dude greg dude don't
be the hater bro do not be a hater man
don't do that don't do that nah nah no
hate no haters
people for a reason the man built for
the reason all right speaking of mvp and
rookie of the year i had a chance to
speak with director of draftkings
sportsbook and long time gaming industry
legend johnny avello on the latest
trends around these markets in the
betting world take a look
johnny welcome to the squad ride really
really happy to have you here we know
you have all the inside scoop on
everything going on in the nfl betting
world so i want to start off with
probably the most prestigious but also
the most simple one most of the times
what are the most popular bets for the
mvp right now and are there any
surprising names finding themselves in
the mix
well the most popular would be patrick
mahomes at five to one with twenty
percent of all the money in that market
uh mahomes was the top wager guy last
season until aaron rodgers backers
jumped on the reigning mvp
approximately halfway through the season
josh allen at 12-1 who was second into
voting last year he's second in the
money bet with 12 percent of overall
handle now you ask about surprises uh
top five matthew stafford who has yet to
win anything in his 12-year nfl career
has taken about 10 percent of the money
he's at 18-1 and justin herbert a
notable year potential star is another
bettors are backing uh speculating on
having just the top season uh herbert
also is 18-1 if you notice that all the
guys top 10 guys in this market they're
all quarterbacks and it makes sense
because quarterbacks have won 17 of the
last 20.
yeah and herbert coming off that
phenomenal rookie season and kicking
things over to the rookies right now
there's been a lot of buzz around justin
fields who are the most popular
offensive rookie of the year bets right
now
well i'm calling this market the justin
fields show this thing is so one-sided
so far it feels has taken 36 percent of
the money 50 percent of the bets
he has absorbed more money than zach
wilson trey uh lance and trevor lawrence
all combined and why not uh out of all
the newbies and particularly the
quarterback so he appears to be that on
a team who's gonna
win quite a few games uh although he
presumably won't start in week one he
should be at the head control shortly
into the season yeah really interesting
considering he definitely will not start
week one that market is wide open
looking at all the wagers right now is
there any line that has significantly
moved since it launched or there are a
couple lines that you've seen a lot of
movement on since they went live there's
actually two with some pretty good
movement first is the seahawks at the
colts the colts opened a one and a half
point favorite now or two and a half
point underdog and this move is based on
a combination of both quarterback
uncertainty that would be carson wentz
and handicapping
the seahawks are perceived as the better
team
the second game with substantial
movement involves the washington
football team who opened as a one and a
half point home favorite over to
chargers and the la team is now taking
over favoritism by one point
this is strictly a handicapped move with
the better siding with justin herbert
over probable ryan fitzpatrick who would
be starting for his ninth
team as a quarterback
johnny you've been doing this for a long
time and with that comes a lot of
changes and draftings this year is
offering a lot of new props
what's the most popular amongst the new
markets that you've seen so far
these regular season matchups we're
doing are really popular for for ins for
instance a passing category more passing
yards ryan tannehill versus joe burrow
that's a pickum russell wilson versus
kirk cousins
that is wilson minus 130. we have one up
for receiving yards lamb versus julio
jones lamb's a dollar 35 favorite a sax
match up with joey boza versus von
miller uh boses a 125 favorite so we
have six to ten different matchups in
multiple categories and this thing is
just going on fire
johnny really appreciate your time man
thank you so much
thanks for having me on
all right a big thanks to johnny you
heard it those justin fields bettors are
probably not too happy about the latest
news that the man somehow is not
starting moving on division winners
division
winners i'm sure the audience will be
real rational on picking these let's
bring up those odds and take a look at
the afc first and see who's expected to
come out on top in the afc
all right you can see across the board
the afc north pretty much wide open
right now besides those poor bengals
down at the bottom the afc east the
bill's expected to reign supreme
although don't sleep on those dolphins
or of course the mack jones-led patriots
out west i don't think a lot of people
are going to be betting against the
chiefs anytime soon and when you look at
the south houston's got plenty of
problems of their own jacksonville with
the rookie by those titans sitting at
the top over there moving on to the nfc
let's see those nfc odds before we get
our expert picks here the packers aaron
rodgers is back they're sitting real
nice in the north you look at the south
not going to be a lot of picks against
tom brady and his bucks the nfc east
wide open right now between them cowboys
with dak prescott of course the
washington football team maybe the
giants all right nfc west same thing
wide open niners rams seahawks on the
mix with the cardinals as the underdog
greg what are the people got going on
right now i'd love to hear their
thoughts
everybody get in the comments and tell
us which team is the best bet to win
their division i'm giving away hoodies
and i'm giving away 250 dk dollars be
what
which team do you think is the best bet
to win their division
titan's for sure
i know you say like connor said houston
got some problems down there a couple i
gotta go with the titans i think they're
gonna run the show for sure
i gotta go with my titans all tanner
hill has to do is just take care of the
ball
and get the ball to the big man in the
backfield and you got two
two hammerhead sharks at wideout
i mean just just take your time and have
fun playing that game with those
talented guys that he has around him
i keep who you rolling with i feel like
you're gonna pick a dark horse here
that's how you kind of roll yeah i'm
gonna pick a dark horse man just because
v y keeping this [ __ ] so simple right
yeah i'm saying i'm gonna go and pick a
dark horse
i think the nfc
west
they're gonna send three to the playoffs
right so they gonna have a bunch of coal
teams in the nfc west
and i'm gonna ride with arizona to be
the 12 and what is it now [ __ ] twelve
and five
five nine twelve and five thirteen and
four i'm arriving arizona 13 and four
plus 650 you know i'm always looking at
that cash too you know what i'm saying
so if i bet i want to pick up some paper
all right i'm wrong with ed's on the
card can't forget my seahawks you can't
get about the seahawks you know mvp
finished i don't know i didn't say what
i didn't say what three teams they gonna
sing i just said they're gonna send
three teams
might be the seahawks
one of them going
one of them gonna have an injury bug one
of them gonna have an injury bug and
that's gonna be the only reason they'll
make it the other three teams gonna be
going ham they're gonna go well i'll
tell you a division that's not sending
three teams that's the nfc north all
right they'll send one team and that's
the green bay packers that's who i'm
rolling with sir i'm not buying in on
plexiglas kirk cousins i wish the bears
would start justin fields i mean this is
pretty much a runaway the lions sorry
might win two to three games this year
never ever anyone makes aaron rodgers
mad he does his best work it's a green
bay all the way greg what do you got for
us who you going with
uh before i get in before i give you
guys my take let me talk to the people
man let me get the people's
uh takes here we go i got uh kevin
gardner's rocking with the raiders by i
am not no hater he's rocking with the
raider shout out to you kevin gardner
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
here we go hawaii 77 says eagles baby
eagles
shout out to you
you are hawaii
away with the hoodie i got one more
hoodie in me they gonna be dirty i got
one more hoodie in me uh
here we go we got chiefs fan 2024 wilson
is gonna carry the jets those odds are
so nice connor i just had to read that
one for you that was for you to just
give you some type of hope connor some
type of hope but
yeah i'm just speaking
speaking of the afc east
i'm gonna go there i'm gonna go there
and i'm going to look at buffalo i'm
going to look at buffalo and i think
i'll go rock with buffalo
because i mean
man they they cool little team out there
man simply because uh that's connor i
mean
shout out to robert sala shout out to my
guy robert sala but you know i just
think they're their pieces away uh new
england we don't mac jones he might be
we we just don't know so i don't know if
i'm willing to put my money on that
miami we also don't know what the
quarterback situation there buffalo
akiba i know you like the value i know
you like the plus money me what i got
going on at br bedding we like winners
only please man and i think this right
here is a winner so i'll take this to
the bank man we're rocking with buffalo
uh
and
i'm giving away that 250 dk dollars i'm
back into the ipad i am back into the
ipad and i got right here right here you
go like this one by jack
zayman's jack zaman's
rocking with tennessee i know
rocky with those titans shout out to you
jack jack zaman
walking away with that 200
v1 all right
all right get on draftkings for more
division winners but now it's time to
talk about the vision winners we're
going to be talking super bowl winner
but before we do that we have a trip to
giveaway and that trip is to las vegas
it's the moment you've all been waiting
for
almost greg tell the people what we got
next
i know v y and the key been waiting for
it and i'm i'm gonna try to put it
together y'all man we gonna try to get
that vegas trip going my secret right
now
hey right now i'm gonna see uh i'm about
to give away one last jersey and a trip
to vegas for one lucky winner
and a friend
what i need you to do is get in the
comments and tell me you're locked to
win the super bowl tell me who you think
is going to win the super bowl that's
the easy bet that's easy well let's see
while everyone does that let's take a
look at the odds to win it all this year
and we knew the chiefs and the bucks are
gonna sit at the top greg's bills he's
officially a member of bill's mafia when
he's on the east coast plus one thousand
pretty good money right there an easy
ten bucks to win a hundred gotta love
that
vince what do you like to win the super
bowl when you look at this list as akivo
he says we're trying to make some money
here we're not playing it's safe all the
time baby
i gotta go with the goat
mr brady he's gonna do it again and
again and again
i know people uh don't like winners for
some reason but um
tom brady is that guy
a keeper you're
better wrong tom definitely the gold
time definitely the goat man but for
sure
you know i like to pick up that paper
man so look i'm i always i'm gonna pick
a dark horse
who really really got a chance you know
what i'm saying so i'm gonna go with the
best defense in the league baby i'm
gonna go with the rams
i'll ride with the rams i'm talking to
you i'm gonna be about to say cleveland
i was like do not say that
nah my dog joe
joe wood's gonna have cleveland defense
together too now they're gonna they're
gonna make a nice little push too but
i'm gonna ride with the rams man the
rams staffer coming to town
if he catch fire and that defense do
what they supposed to do man that's a
that's that's a great bet plus what is
plus 1400 come on now yeah big time
money for that duo then with the rams
aaron donald jalen ramsey tough to find
a better defensive duo in all the nfl
than that i'm gonna roll with the guys
yeah pretty nice out there pretty nice
out there i'm gonna roll out here i look
at it i'm going with the guys that score
a lot of points they're coming off
obviously disappointing super bowl loss
yeah it's only plus 500 it's a coward
bet don't care rolling with the chiefs
greg what you got
[Laughter]
hey i like that connor do not care man
put that money down uh before i get into
what i got i'm in the comments man i'm
in the comments uh
big bird big ex big bird x says buffalo
bill shout out to you big bird you're
walking away with a hoodie uh i got you
big mad they say you big mad rocking
with the 49er super bowl champ shout out
to you big mad you were also rocking
away with the hoodie uh
here we go one more hoodie b marshall 91
b marshall 91 said
they are rocking with the titans my guy
be wife
actually
let's pull that graphic back up though
let's pull that let's pull that let's
pull that uh nfl championship graphic
back up and let's walk through it
i'm not i'm the kansas city chiefs or
plus 500 and we're not going to be chalk
eating right now we're not going to pick
the favorites so we're just going to
move on tampa bay super bowl hangover
i'm sorry v.y
i know you believe in brady but that's
not happening buffalo
now i know i talked about buffalo a lot
i know i talked about buffalo a lot but
i don't know if they have enough to beat
the chiefs so i i'm not going to pick
them i'm not going to pick buffalo green
bay they're going to lose to the niners
so we're just going to skip over them
baltimore uh lamar jackson he got to
show me something in in the postseason
so we're also going to skip on them and
guess where we land at guess where we
land at the san francisco
49ers yes the san francisco 49ers jimmy
g trey lance at the quarterback the dual
quarterback we might see it b.y
mike shanahan might do something jews
might do something we've never seen
before
hey d'amico ryan's leading the defense
man
doing match-ups out there man i like the
niners they was just like tonight i'm a
call shanahan fan i'm a college fan but
to win the big show i don't know i don't
know
to win it be why they was just there two
years ago that was right there last year
we got hurt we got hurt a lot of people
got hurt like man
no no no no
i'm putting my money on them nine is man
it's a good bet i like it we go we go
see
we go see now let me give out this
jersey man let me get out this jersey
i'm back into the i'm back into the i'm
back into the comments back into the
comments and i see uh
i see
davey hold on hold on the comments are
jumping
yeah we're just trying to move on we
bout to move on
oh damn yeah that is a tough break for
david
feel bad for you say something so bad
for you right you'll win
game pro 50 game pro 50 you guys are
going to probably think this one's kind
of rigged my guy conor says i'm a new
i'm a new uh bills fan but i'm rocking
with the niners man until i die but
bills
diggs and allen are coming back on a
mission that's what gamepro 50 said he
said the bills diggs and allen are
coming back on the mission shout out to
you game pro 50 you are walking away
with the gift card for the jersey uh
not bad all right you gave away the
jersey
i mean everybody's waiting for it let's
be real it's the elephant in the room
right now we want to know who's going to
vegas or maybe with a cave and vy right
now so greg how did they win this vegas
trip
um trying to set it up by the squad ride
squad for a reason trying to set it up
baby hey you all have been in the
comments dropping your super bowl locks
now we're going to give
the wheel a spin with all 32 nfl teams
whichever team it lands on i'm picking
one random person who picked that team
to win the trip to las vegas v y
akeeb before i spin this wheel before we
spin this pool
y'all been talking a big vegas game
y'all been talking like y'all really
want to pull up to vegas so like
what's your favorite what's your
favorite table game to play when you at
the casino
gotta go poker baby
poker oh
okay
read people's faces and stuff like that
you know because when i sit down at the
table i'm putting fear in somebody's
chest already
[Laughter]
i don't touch the poker table though i
don't really touch the poker table keep
it simple yeah i'm saying i'm a 21 type
of guy
blackjack
[Laughter]
savage man hey uh all right y'all ready
it's time to spin this wheel connor or
do it man i want to see who's going to
vegas let's do it
a key v y y'all ready man let's do it
hey
let's do it let's spin this wheel spin
that thing spin it go
spin it spin it niners niners niners yes
they see some in them boys man i'm
telling you hey
defense and run game win tips man
the only reason
wow the only reason i say that because
i'm a long lord and they've got a guy
that's from ou that play quarterback and
you know oh you sucks
oh that's the madness that's the secret
to that madness behind that brown cause
he been talking he even talked about it
yeah there you go
now i see why now i see why i see it now
i see why
yeah hey the wheel picked the brown so
someone who took the browns is walking
away with the trip
to las vegas i'm about to get into the
comments right now i'm about to get into
the comments here we go hb shanio hb
shanio la charge no hb shanio you are
not winning the trip but guess what you
are walking away with a hoodie shout out
to you hb shinio uh here we go i got
i got laden aladdin is in here
l-a-d-d-i-n he is rocking with the
niners i love that ladder yeah i love
that to the core there you go i love
that to the core but i just cannot give
you
the trip to vegas just not yet but you
were walking away with the hoodie shout
out to you ladder
now nick smith 4-1-7 nick smith 4-1-7
b-y you go like this tighten up
tighten up
unfortunately i just i don't feel it in
me to give you this vegas trip i'm sorry
but i'm giving you a hoodie i am giving
you a hoodie you were walking away with
it
all right here we go here we go for the
marbles let's let's let's let's stop
playing man this the vegas trip is here
who's going to vegas
who's going to be we're going to vegas
hey
b
losser b losser 74 b losser 74 had the
browns at the browns
74
you
are going to las vegas you and a friend
i gotta say this i gotta say this right
now i gotta say this
or the lawyers will get mad and i might
not have my job next week and now we do
not want that so i gotta say this this
is subject to verification this is
subject to verification might be a kid
or something you heard the man you heard
the man all right i hope you had fun
here today hopefully every i think
everyone took home prizes even if you
got a hoodie you're going to vegas
whatever it may be get on draftkings and
check out everything in your local
markets and of course right now they
have a no-brainer back guys bucks plus
73 free
money you know what that means that
means if the bucks
all the bucks have to do is not lose by
more than 73 points and you are a winner
that's easy money that's a v y pick
that's a me pick not an easy man that's
what we do here that's what we do here
all right the squad ride is back sunday
week 1 11 a.m eastern time greg and i
will be back before kickoff in the
bleacher report app come see us get
hoodies get prizes get jerseys whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa connor connor connor
before i feel like you're about to wrap
it up man i feel we've been here for a
while i feel you like you bout to wrap
it up so before we wrap it up
handy dandy is back out i'm giving away
hoodies man i am giving away hoodies uh
here we go uh davey24 bill's mafia shout
out to you you're walking away with a
hoodie uh here we go woke jesus please
be woke woke jesus please oh no but woke
jesus it says that the champa the champa
bay bucks the tampa bay bucks shout out
to you whoa jesus you were walking away
with a hoodie i like that i like that
right one more
one more one more one more here we go
jonathan cooper
vy you go like this man tennessee titans
i apologize man but i just gotta feed
the people go ahead they stayed around
and they won all right thanks to vince
young thanks to a keith to leave
alongside greg ivory
that's a good idea i'm connor rogers if
you've won something whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa connor connor connor connor more
maybe
more more more we got to give away a
jersey bro we gotta give away
[Music]
i believe that's how you pronounce it
they're rocking with the steelers to win
it all rocking with the steelers you are
walking away with the gift card
to get a jersey get that nazi hair hey
connor all right promise you promise i
promise you
got it you got a las vegas strip in your
back pocket right now that you're going
to give away for anyone that stayed
around all right
man
good
hold on hold on hold on hold on the
producer is whispering hold up the
producer is whispering something into my
ear please whisper it back into my ear i
think we might be giving away something
else connor hold on
the producer is whispering it's
something that's oh
give him
[Music]
all right we're going to give away some
2k dk dollars d we have more money to
give away back into the comments back
into the comments
uh
back into the comments
cowboys over the bills less less ross
garza lee ross garza lee ross garza
cowboys over the bill you're walking
away with 250 dk dollars i'm being
generous right now i'm being generous
right now uh
b losser 74 said he's in walmart
tripping out right now please send us
that video we need that video connor all
right bro
that wasn't me no i don't know
i love it
that was all in my ear bro all right
let's go thanks for watching everyone
catch your week one
[Music]
you